[Aplausos]
um grau 2 graus
o 3° quando a gente está com grau acima
da temperatura o nosso corpo ideal seja
estaremos com 37 graus
a gente tem um leve mal estar correto
com 2 graus cima 38° coisa começa a
ficar desagradável gente já não tem
aquela concentração necessárias como
essa calafrio não é não dá pra viver
levar isso muito bem com três graus
acima com 39 graus aí vocês sabem a cama
né e aí já não dá pra conduzir uma vida
normal
então a gente tem que começar a entender
o que significam grau de diferença
grande diferença é a água no estado
sólido versus o estado líquido
2° de diferença pra nós cozinheiros a
diferença entre um chocolate em barra
com um chocolate que a gente usa pra
cozinhar
já em estado líquido nossa presença no
planeta terra
ela é relativamente recente
então nesse período a gente teve mais ou
menos o andamento da concentração de co2
e andamento da temperatura que vocês
podem ver e foi mais ou menos
em paralelo e sempre com diferenças não
tão expressivas até o momento em que de
repente começa um pico
só que está muito concentrado agora que
acontece desde aí entre 50 e 80 a
porcentagem de
eventos extremos climáticos é quase não
dá pra ver zero a 0 1% então era um
eventual vocês já podem ver que dá pra
perceber a há a presença de eventos
extremos climáticos e na década seguinte
está claro está nítido está lá e agora
chegamos a ter mais ou menos tem de 10%
da da da superfície do planeta afetada
por eventos climáticos extremos
na realidade e menos do que a causa é o
efeito onde que fica sem efeito as
pessoas acham que a mesma mudança
climática é distribuída na mudança
climática é pouco distribuir ela se
concentra mais nos oceanos e isso faz
toda a diferença
veja aí eu a mudança climática nos
oceanos e veja aí como gosta disso o
furacão furacão ele escolhe exatamente
os caminhos das anomalias de
temperaturas para cima que acontecem
acima do nível do mar
mas o que nos interessa é que por conta
daquela coisa dos oceanos é o ciclo
hidrológico na terra que se intensifica
e aí o que nos interessa é ver que hoje
isso acontece em diferentes áreas do
mundo afetando a vida do mais pobre
afetando a vida do mais rico de formas
diferentes afetando a vida no sul do
planeta afetando a vida no norte do
planeta ficando a nossa infraestrutura
aquela que a gente constrói para
transporte para energia afetando a nossa
economia afetando o pib afetando aquilo
que a gente curte
uma utilizar como medição da nossa
riqueza como a base para a troca entre
países entre indivíduos entre empresas
aqui nos últimos anos tivemos uma
intensificação as empresas cedentes
desse tipo de fenômenos extremos e vocês
vêem que a água ela vai se concentrando
a mudança do ciclo do ciclo hidrológico
ela faz com que ela entre nos lugares em
que não estava planejado para ela está
não se trata necessariamente de um drama
para o planeta porque planeta continuam
aquela mesma água de um problema
principalmente pra quem planejou fazer
com que aquela água esteja aqui nesse
estado o haka e nesse outro estado
líquido gasoso ou sólido principalmente
vocês sabem aquela que está em estado
sólido caso das geleiras e mas aquela
que está em estado gasoso que aquela que
se mexe rapidamente na atmosfera e que
ela está sujeita a mudanças extremamente
radicais e aqui vocês sabem que quando
os eventos extremos têm um impacto
econômico tão impacto social e tem
principalmente um homem impacto também é
de relações políticas de segurança
porque se aumenta nos conflitos que se
geram novos conflitos a partir dessas
situações
se eu vou reduzir o turismo nas
cataratas por conta daquela a situação
ou se eu tenho um país que diminui sua
produção sua exportação
dado momento eu tenho houve a mente
efeitos não só dentro deles mas mais
amplos
então é importante entender
lembrem a água é sempre a mesma que a
mudança na distribuição na localização
da água é a mesma que gera também as
secas ou seja vai faltar água o que tem
água em demasia de novo lembra a água
onde a gente não planejou para efeito da
agricultura para efeito de distribuição
de infraestrutura das nossas torneiras
das nossas cidades do nosso consumo que
a gente achou que ela deveria estar lá
ea gente fez investimentos entendendo
que ela deveria estar lá está em outro
lugar então as secas são tenha
exatamente a mesma origem daquilo
daquelas inundações que vocês acaba de
ver o mesmo calor que vá por água do
oceano é também o mesmo vá porque faz
evaporar a água da terra gerando aceita
em outro lugar enquanto concentra a água
bem se isso representa dos dois lados um
problema para nossa convivência humana
vamos ver como é a perspectiva da seca
são directamente ver como está agora e
aqui estamos já em 39 graus em 2006
então e aqui é o cenário já com febre há
40 que ele vai chegar antes do fim do
fim do século aí já fica difícil o close
aqui na nossa região a gente já sabe
hoje como é conviver com isso
nos últimos 18 meses a principal causa
da cor da crise da nossa atual
conjuntura econômica esse aqui perdemos
um ano e meio 15 bilhões de dólares no
câmbio de hoje são 60
bilhões de reais só na agricultura
brasileira
temos um país que tem algumas vantagens
e algumas desvantagens muita dependência
de recurso natural significa vantagem
por alguns aspectos significa
vulnerabilidade do outro
agora algo que vocês não estão
acostumadas a vincular uma coisa com a
outra
é isso aqui porque vocês todos conhecem
essa imagem de 15 dias atrás
mas há o como começou isso quando um
país chega na situação em que chegou à
síria
no final da década passada os refugiados
começa a se acumular e começa a
abandonar áreas enormes do país que
antes eles utilizavam inclusive deixando
de produzir uma série de coisas
importantes até para exportação
quando estava claro que isso estava fora
do controle
o mundo não percebeu e percebi agora por
um outro indicador que é o refugiado
globalizado um grau um grau aquela
diferença entre a água em estado sólido
estado líquido
apenas um grau pode alterar as colheitas
de trigo 20 1% e no milho está pior na
soja está um pouquinho melhor mais a
área é maior e efeito acumulado na
economia é maior porque a soja significa
depois também a proteína dos animais e
portanto a carne e portanto outras
coisas
quando nós temos situações como aquela
que tivemos em 2012 com aquela subida de
repente dos dos alimentos por conta
daquelas mesma situação que afetava
síria hospital afectando em certa medida
também alguns dos grandes produtores
será nicolas do mundo que interromperam
na exportação de grãos
nós temos um sinal de situação alarme
vermelho do ponto de vista da segurança
global os motivos
azahar as migrações estão lá é para
sinalizar a isso e junto com isso uma
série de outros probleminhas pragas é
ter a coisa que a gente não sabe
exatamente como controlar um grau um
grau e meio é suficiente e bom como tudo
tem outro lado é oportunidades que se
abrem com isso tem atividades econômicas
que podem ter nichos que vão se
desenvolver a partir dessas crises quem
sabe os vendedores de água mineral
mantém uma grande oportunidade por
exemplo em determinadas áreas do planeta
para posicionar seu produto né de forma
diferente do que fizeram esse senhor
inventou um food traquila na china
fantástico de repente o rio de janeiro
sofre agora a concorrência de alguém que
não estava previsto que porque pode-se
chegar a concorrer com e ipanema
mas o problema é que o cara do futebol
aqui para me meter tudo junto todas
novas oportunidades até água mineral num
compete com isso isso é maior
vocês podem perceber que existe uma
massa crítica de investimento ameaçado e
se senhoras que são aqueles que nos
falando de um grande upgrade do ingresso
de investimentos ou eles que nos explica
como funciona tanto que alguns governos
já se reúnem em condição mais adequada
então o que tem no final pra quando tem
um prejuízo que que onde vai o prejuízo
pra alguém para algum seguro né e o
seguro vai para o resseguro então no
final no mundo
economia tem duas grandes empresas uma é
essa que o resseguro tudo neto tudo o
que é grande prejuízo bati nela e ela se
entender aquelas são insustentáveis por
quem não tem volume de garantias de aval
abaixo para sustentar o volume do preju
que vem dos seguros que vem dos eventos
climáticos extremos e portanto no final
é uma questão econômica dizem os
senhores das resseguradoras
é isso que nós deveríamos garantir
frente a essa variabilidade bem então a
mudança climática não é uma ameaça para
a terra ela do ponto de vista de
espécies invasores do dia aumento da
alteração da denominação competitiva ela
pode gerar um monte de novas espécies
que podem se dar muito bem no planeta
a dificuldade é ficar do nosso lado e é
com isso que nós temos uma
responsabilidade ligar de lidar agora
daqui a dois meses em paris como vocês
sabem e foi o recado então que nós temos
que dar para os políticos que vão se
reunir já com água próxima do limite em
paris
esse é o recado que a terra nos dá
preocupe-se como 6 mesmos
obrigado
[Aplausos]
[Música]